hey everyone it's pete soderling i'm the
founder of data council
and the data community fund
i'm excited to have another episode of
dc thursday to share with you all
as you know we interview
amazing data leaders
who are often starting companies or
open source projects and advancing the
modern data ecosystem
and today
we're very fortunate to have anapalm
data
who's the co-founder of a model an ai
quality company
called truera
anapalm is a professor at carnegie
mellon university
and he received a phd in cs from
stanford so anapalm um thanks for
joining us and and welcome
thank you pete thanks for having me
so on a palm um we're going to talk a
lot about ai quality today and
what that really means and i'm i'm
looking forward to to hearing your
thoughts
um but i wanted to sort of
start off with a bit about your
background
um you're obviously very well well
pedigreed and i'm curious like how did
you
make the decision originally to go into
academia
that's a great question
i think that decision
i made back when i was in sixth grade
so my dad was a professor of statistics
and
um i have always been very excited about
teaching and learning
at that time i didn't know what field
but i was pretty sure
that
the professionally
i would end up being an academic
and at stanford i was very fortunate to
work
with a number of outstanding
collaborators
and it got
that thought got even more ingrained i
was excited about the research i was
doing
back then in areas around privacy and
security
and i was just
excited about
the
the whole research experience and the
academic life which combines research
with teaching and mentoring
and having curiosity driven research
that can go on to have a positive impact
on the world
and and so how did that transition into
the field of ai
so
i continued to work
on privacy
uh once i joined cmu
in 2007
and over time
over the course of the next three four
years
what became very apparent
is that
some of the big challenges in privacy
were arising in the context of machine
learning
and ai so as ai models got increasingly
deployed
how do how do these models
uh
potentially leak information
about the people who are in the training
data
and what can we do to train machine
learning models in a way that
respects privacy
and
related to that
i had also started
thinking a little bit about
studying privacy related properties of
existing systems
that are widely deployed and
back in 2013
uh 2013 2014
my research group did a study of the
google
online advertising system
and
initially we were thinking about this in
the context of privacy that for example
is health information about people being
used to target advertisements to them
which would be concerning from a privacy
standpoint
but relatedly
uh in an adjacent area the question of
fairness also emerged
for example
our employment opportunities being
targeted
in ways that make
use of people's gender
or ethnic character racial
characteristics and so forth
and one of the outcomes of that study
one of the things we discovered in the
process of that study was
that
information about gender was being used
to target certain kinds of employment
opportunities
in a way that raised questions about the
fairness of these systems
and under the hood there's a lot of
machine learning
driving many of these behaviors
and then we took a step back
and and started asking
deeper questions about
why is this kind of behavior
why are these systems
exhibiting certain forms of bias based
on gender and so forth
and that why question then
expanded into
the questions around explainability of
machine learning systems
and more broadly how explainability
could be leveraged to answer questions
of ai quality questions around fairness
questions around stability and
robustness of models
and more generally about
understanding how well
models will generalize
to new data and continue to perform well
in production
and so
at the time
i think um
[Music]
sort of you know
this umbrella um
you've defined as ai quality
um
this this research you kicked off
um many years ago i'm curious like what
was the state of
sort of the understanding
in the ai ml ecosystem
at this time i'm i assume that that ai
quality was not really a term that was
used then i'm curious like what was the
state of the union from your perspective
yeah that's a great question pete
you're exactly right back in 2013 or 14
there was a very small community of
people
who were starting to ask these questions
and
one of the
one of the early
conferences that
got pulled together
by a small group of people and i was
part of that
initial set
uh what's called fairness accountability
and transparency in machine learning
so the transparency piece is close to
what we are calling explainability
these days fairness has still remained
an important topic
and accountability was drawing attention
to the fact that
as you think about these kinds of
technical problems it's also important
to have
think of them more broadly as
socio-technical problems to certain
individuals
in various kinds of roles
who are responsible
to ensure that the systems respect
certain kinds of
societal values
so that conference has now grown to
become
a very central place for this community
that hundreds of people go to
it's now called
the fact conference
fairness accountability and transparency
it has become an acm conference
and it pulls together folks from
computer science and law
and
philosophy
social sciences it's grown into a very
multidisciplinary community
i think that that's one piece of the ai
quality problem
it's an important piece
which is the social impact of the
technology and it goes by various names
there's the fact community
sometimes people refer to as a
responsible ai
but there's also another set of pillars
around ai quality
which get to the heart of
how well
is are your models going to perform in
the real world
which is the generalization question
they're related but
somewhat distinct questions
and as we think about ai quality
at least the way i think about it now is
how how do you think about how should we
go about assessing ai
systems and models and data so that we
can
make a more direct connection to their
impact
on the end
organizational value or business value
as well as the social impact through
fairness transparency
uh privacy and other related attributes
so so what what you're saying is that um
there's sort of a bigger grab bag of
aspects that go into ai ai quality and
um
the performance of the models
is only one aspect there's the
the bigger questions of
did the model sort of reach
the intended business goal
um
did it apply
its predictions
sort of fairly and uniformly
um
basically it's sort of your seems like
you're expanding this notion
of ai quality
um
maybe sometimes people from a technical
perspective think of
model monitoring
um but you're actually making the
conversation much larger is the way i
understand it
yeah that's exactly right and
historically when
data scientists are building models
there has been a lot of focus on the
accuracy of those models what are the
auc characteristics
roc roc and f1 scores and so forth
depending on the type of the model which
is evaluated on the train test and
validation data
and that was the leading indicator if
you will of ai quality in the sense of
how well will it do in production
what we are seeing now
as part of this ai quality effort is
that
that continues to remain an important
indicator of how well the model will do
in production in the real world
in terms of delivering business value
but there's a whole set of other
attributes that one should also assess
during model development and on an
ongoing basis through monitoring when
the model is in production
some of them you touched on like
fairness related metrics for example
which has real significance and impact
especially when this is personal
information about people about
individuals and their lives can be
impacted
in credit decisioning
in hiring and employment related use
cases where machine learning is
increasingly being used
uh in areas around healthcare for
example medical diagnostics and so forth
but for the generalization piece of the
model as well
just looking at
metrics around auc and so forth accuracy
metrics
is not a very good indicator it's not a
sufficient indicator of how well the
model will do in production
so there are other elements around the
robustness of the models
robustness in this in the sense meaning
that if you change
your inputs a little bit
for certain kinds of models you expect
the outputs to also change a little bit
so we see that a lot with image
recognition models for example
uh
facial recognition technology
is being fed an input
the image
let's say is that a foreign land of
bloom
and the model correctly recognizes it as
orlando blue
and then
a few pixels get changed here and there
you would expect to human it still looks
like orlando bloom
but a model that's not robust
will think might end up thinking that
it's true barrymore
so we've seen a lot of examples of
models that might have high accuracy
metrics on train and test validation
data
but are not very robust and so when
they're fed these inputs
this images in this example that are
slightly different
then they make
very dramatic errors
in their classification
so that's an example of one kind of ai
quality attribute that
requires additional constraints during
training and adjustments to ensure that
models generalize well another one is
stability of models over time
in that case what we are looking at is
the model does really well on train and
test data
and now suddenly
you have put the model in production and
the world has changed
and some of the relationships that used
to be true before are no longer true and
so the model starts performing poorly
being able to understand and anticipate
that that's about to happen
and why it's about to happen
what is it that has changed about the
world that's causing this change
is very very powerful
so for example
one concrete instance of this is
as as models started making their way
into production
uh
post covet
then some of the relationships have
that used to be true before
may no longer be true
so for example
uh fico scores used to be a good
indicator of
credit
credit worthiness but in the early days
of covet
when people had gotten payment vacations
then delinquencies were not being
reported and so fico scores were not
going down
for folks whose credit worthiness had
gone down
so in that time
a model that was relying overly on fico
scores
to identify folks who are not
going to be able to
make the payments
would not be a very
well performing model
so that's one kind of example
and there's lots of others people's
spending behavior changed quite a bit
during covet so models that are
marketing models
that were trained on old data would not
do a very good job of predicting how to
target folks
with with offers and
products
so that's that's another kind of
attribute of ai quality
which is if you think about the
generalization problem there's
generalization over time as well and
it's extremely important to recognize
that relationships that are learned
during training may not be
persistent over time so it's important
to track
and monitor them and debug
when performance is starting to degrade
why is it degrading and what should we
do to readjust the model to bring it up
to its original level of
performance
got it
so so basically you felt like these
problems were
common enough and important enough you
decided to start a company
in the space um so tell us like what's
the
what's the brief origin story of truera
and how did the company come to be
sure
so as i mentioned we started working on
some of these problems back in 2013 2014
and
um
around 2017
somewhere around
august or september of 2017
is
when i seriously started thinking about
starting a company
and one of my
phd students from that time shayaxan
who was working on this on these topics
around explainability and fairness in
particular
and had previously been an algorithmic
trader on wall street where he was
building and deploying machine learning
models and high stakes use cases
he he was also very excited about the
idea so the two of us started
thinking about starting a company
and
i went around and talked to some of my
friends who had successfully done
startups in the past
and one of the best pieces of advice i
got at that time was to
go and have 75 conversations
across a range of verticals with
potential customers
to understand if there is a market for
something like this and what the state
of maturity of the market is so that's
what we did over the course of the next
year while we were continuing to push on
the technology
we spent a lot of time talking to folks
across the board in financial services
banking insurance in health care number
of health care providers
hospital systems
we talk to folks in
more cloud-native companies in the gig
economy
who were
technologically uh more
like not not not a more traditional
business where there are legal legacy
systems and such but they were they
started off in the cloud and were
early adopters of machine learning
in the gig economy so you can guess some
of the companies in that space
uh fintechs
and and across the board there was this
recognition
that
the core of
what we are now calling ai quality
is
extremely extremely important and
there's a lack of tooling
to support
data scientists and ml ops folks
in going about the job of explaining
their models to stakeholders testing and
debugging them
and keeping track of them through
monitoring
so towards the end of 2018
uh we incorporated shack and i
incorporated the company and started
talking to a few friendly vcs and
through one of those conversations we
were introduced to
william huppington who
was at that time chief product officer
of a company called bloomreach
bloombridge had been founded by
ex-google folks and was taking
algorithmic
systems including machine learning
to
enterprise retail customers
and in his in talking to will there was
a strong resonance in that he had
experienced some of the same problems
from uh
from a sales and customer success
and product perspective where
with without the ability to answer
questions about what was going on under
the hood the black box nature of machine
learning
in those days
it was very hard to
convince customers to adopt machine
learning
in use cases where it was central to
their business
and so we came together and
will joined us as a co-founder
and then we then
raised our first round of funding
uh it was led by greylock
uh and a couple of other investors
joined us as well and so this was in
april of 2019 and and then we started
operating in june of 2019 we're about
two years in we have
come quite some distance since those
early days
got it
that's that's amazing
um so
so tell us about
um i mean i think
we have a sort of backdrop as to
um why you believe ai quality is
important
um but tell us a little bit more about
the truera
solution and how the product works
sure
so
um the true era
suite of products
are aimed at
ensuring
the quality of ai systems the models the
data
and there are
two
products that we currently have that
work closely together
the first
is is a diagnostic product
and
that integrates
neatly into the
model development environment
so when data scientists are building
machine learning models
the workflow into which we fit in
involves
involves
it involves them building their machine
learning models in whatever model
development environment they're used to
a lot of our customers use open source
libraries to build machine learning
models xgboost for example is very
popular a lot of python models
there's also tensorflow and pi torch the
neural network frameworks which lots of
folks use to build models
and then there are also folks who use
more
proprietary platforms like data robot or
h2o to build models
one of the unique things about our
diagnostics product is that
it fits in
easily into and works
with seamlessly with lots of diff models
produced by lots of different model
development platforms
so there was some
intentionality at an architectural level
to make our diagnostics product
and in general our entire product suite
agnostic
to
the specifics of a model development
platform and that's an area of
differentiation and strength for us
and philosophically
we are coming from the standpoint that
testing and evaluation and explanation
of machine learning models
should be tightly integrated with the
training ecosystem
but there should also be
modularity extensibility and
independence between that component
between that product and the training
platform
and we see that
if you think about an analogy with
software for example
the software
the core
coding software development ides and the
cicd pipelines
tend to be separate
and work well with each other so there's
a very direct analogy architecturally to
that
and what we're also seeing with our
enterprise customers is that
they are appreciating
that
that separation while having ease of
integration
because it gives them a single pane of
glass
to
keep to assess and keep track of the
quality of their models that may have
been built in many different model
development platforms so within the same
enterprise
there are teams building python models
and teams doing r models
and teams making use of platforms like
data robot to build models
and they can all go through the same
ai quality diagnostics platform to
support testing debugging and
explanation
so that's a powerful
area of strength architecturally and
there's a lot of work that has gone into
building
building this kind of platform
so that's number one
number two
what's unique about our diagnostic
product
is
it has a set of capabilities for data
scientists
to
assess a very rich and comprehensive set
of ai quality attributes
around explainability around fairness of
models
their stability over time
to conduct error analysis
data debugging and so forth
and
at a core technology level there are
some significant differences in the
core technologies for explainability as
well that we can get into
so that's the first
kind of product and then the second
product which is the monitoring product
is
similarly designed to be
agnostic to the specifics of the
deployment platform
or the back end data stores
and can fit in seamlessly into the
production environments
to support ongoing monitoring and there
again we have a set of
unique capabilities
for data scientists uh and mlof's folks
to
keep track of their models
get alerts
along with a root cause analysis of
why those alerts are being sent
so i'll pause here there's
lots of detail we can get into in
each of these buckets
uh but if you want to take the
conversation in a specific direction
uh happy to get into more details
got it
yeah so i guess um just to understand um
sort of the broader place where this is
applicable
um talk to us a little bit about what
customers and what industries
have found this technology most useful
so far
yeah
absolutely so i think in terms of our
vision
we believe that
this kind of ai quality
products
is going to be important across the
board so pretty much anyone who's
building and deploying machine learning
models
needs an ai quality solution to help
them with testing debugging explanation
and monitoring of
models and we are starting to see
evidence of that hypothesis that it's a
very horizontal
offering that's useful across the board
some examples of where we have found
traction
and resonance
is
includes financial services
for example
major banks
as they are
playing as they are starting to use
machine learning in
various kinds of use cases around credit
decisioning
fraud detection
those are areas where
there's a very clear need for ai quality
assessments
and then leveraging that guidance to
improve their models
as you may be aware in the us
there is a lot of regulatory activity
around this area
the major regulators for the
financial services companies
the occ the federal reserve and the
consumer financial protection
have put out an rfi a request for
information
around the use of ai in a way that
speaks very directly to the problem of
the quality
of the models
and the associated model risk
there is
guidance that is starting to emerge in
various other parts of the world
the eu
regulation
draft that was being circulated for ai
talks about an ai quality management
system
that
various
enterprises will be expected to have in
place
to ensure that
their systems are trustworthy
that they
have capabilities for explainability for
fairness for assessing stability and
robustness of models over time
so so that's one big vertical financial
services banking insurance where
there is an immediate and urgent
pull for this kind of solution
we are also starting to see this in a
number of other areas
one of our
customers is
a major
retailer
and
they are
using machine learning for
pricing and marketing related
activities
and in that context
if the model goes out of whack
then there is real and significant
business value
that can get lost so that there's a very
direct connection between the quality of
the ai system
and the impact it has on the business
businesses bottom line
so that's another
area where there's
a lot of interest and activity
uh
for for air equality
are also starting to see
a lot of interest in healthcare
[Music]
and interest also from
smaller
companies not just the big enterprises
but also from smaller companies and data
science teams
who
are currently
using
a lot of have to do a lot of manual work
to test and debug their models to ensure
that they perform well in production
so
i would say that there are a few these
are some of the few articles some of the
verticals and use cases where we are
seeing attention
with
early signals that
it's going to be important across the
board as
companies big and small
adopt machine learning at scale
got it
um so
so tell us like why is
why is this complicated
um for a team to implement on their own
like
sort of what what did you see before
your product existed like how are teams
solving this or attempting to solve this
on their own and what were some of the
challenges there
yeah
that's a great question
i think
one kind of observation is that
this is emerging this is a new and
emerging category
and
for a section of the population
there wasn't widespread recognition that
this even is a problem so that's
starting to change now
data science teams were building their
models optimizing for
accuracy metrics during train and test
and starting to move those models into
production
and sometimes they got stuck because
they could not convince their business
stakeholders
and models would
die
stayed in kind of the r d stage and did
not make it to production
sometimes they would make it to
production
but then not deliver business value the
production performance was nowhere near
what the performance was for
on the train and test data
and there was a lot of
manual debugging and adjustment of
models that had to be done
now
as we move forward in time
folks are
also in in-house are
starting to work on some aspects of this
problem by leveraging
libraries that are available in open
source so there are open source
libraries
for
explainability
and fairness
and so forth
and
those are reasonable starting points for
the slices of the problem
i would say
as we think about
why an independent and complete
enterprise great product is needed here
there are a few different
dimensions to it
one is
at an architectural level and platform
level
it's extremely important to have
a general extensible universal platform
that can work with lots of different
model types that can connect to lots of
different kinds of data stores
and
perform at scale
so so that's
not so easy for data science teams to
pull together
on their own because it requires serious
infrastructure architectural thinking
and
um
execution
so so that's an area where
there is some
serious thinking that went into the
product that we built
for example
ensuring the
universality of our platform meaning
that it can seamlessly work with
lots of different model types and data
types that
are coming out of different model
development platforms
and to to solve that problem we have
built
it stood on the shoulders of giants if
you will
leveraging
a lot of work that
uh
other folks have done like on the ml
flow system
and then
so that's the platform level things
the platform level characteristics then
there's the data science level
characteristics
and there
as we talk about say explainability for
example
it's a
it's a very rich area
and
there are lots of different ways of
explaining models
but there isn't
a very systematic understanding
of for which problem what method works
best
or where the limitations are of
various existing methods
so one of the things where which we have
done as part of our product is to have a
much more guided experience
and to have and we have some core
uh ip that helps with
getting accurate and faster explanations
in a way that has significant impact
for the business
so just to give you one example
if you think about
let's say a credit decisioning system
machine learning model and it's coming
up with specific predictions on who to
give credit to and who not to give
credit to
one of the requirements is to be and
this is required in the us and is
increasingly being discussed in other
parts of the world as well is to answer
questions like why was jane denied
credit relative to a set of people who
are approved
now
what you get out of an explainability
library is here are the top features
along with
feature important scores that say
maybe the income
the debt to income ratio and the number
of delinquent recent missed payments
could be the top drivers
if we get into that next layer of detail
one kind of
emerging
way of
consensus is emerging around the use of
sharply value-based explanations
for
identifying the most important features
this is something that
shake and i worked on and published a
paper back in 2016
and then there have been a series of
follow-up work in this area
and as a company we have
significantly improved
the performance of of the of the method
as well
now one of the hard things about
computing shortly values is that
it's a very expensive computation if you
want to do it exactly
if you have 100 features
that will require like 2 to the power
100 operations which is
just not computationally feasible to do
in a reasonable amount of time
so
then
the next question is how do we estimate
these sharply values
accurately
and fast
so this
requirement around accurate estimation
of sharpening values while still being
very performant
that's a really really hard problem
and
some of the solutions that are in open
source
work well for certain kinds of use cases
but not for other kinds of use cases
so for example
tree shop
works well
if you are trying to explain
find the top features
for a tree model like a gradient boosted
model
or
or a random forest model
and
only if you're trying to explain the log
odd score
coming out of these models
but if you're trying to explain a
classification decision like why was
jane denied credit
the top features
can vary
a lot the sharply values for the most
important features can be very very
different
based on whether you're trying to
explain the classification outcome
or you're trying to explain
a love odd score
and you can get
quite incorrect answers
if you're using one to
infer
answers for the next and maybe an
analogy here is useful so if you think
about the us presidential election for
example
and you're trying to answer the question
of which states are the most important
in determining the outcome of the
election
that's a classification question
and
the answer to that question let's say in
the 2020
election was a state like pennsylvania
if you're trying to instead answer the
question of which states were the most
important in determining the total
electoral college votes that a candidate
got
which is a bit like the log odds
question or the regression score
question
then the answer could be is usually
states like california or texas which
are the bigger states they bring more
votes
so now if you're starting to if you
start try using the
answers for the
regression score or total electoral vote
count score to answer the question about
the classification outcomes you can get
very inaccurate answers and that's where
some of the
gaps are in
in the
uh in some existing methods
[Music]
and so um look
what are some of the
different differentiations between
um what you've built and some of the
other so-called
explainability
tools on the market i'm curious
to understand more about sort of your
values
and
the design decisions you made and some
of the trade-offs
that you considered when you were
building
a generalizable solution in this space
right
so we started getting into some of those
topics
i would say that
there are some very substantial
differences in the core explainability
capabilities
we started getting into that a little
bit where when we talk about sharply
value-based explanations
our methods
are more broadly applicable
they can work with different types of
models they can work with different
types of model outputs
and they're more accurate and performant
if we start getting into some of the
other kinds of capabilities let's say
around fairness around stability of
models
some of the key differentiation there is
around
supporting very rich root cause analysis
so
it's it's
fairly common to
report metrics related to fairness
and in the fairness literature there's a
rich set of metrics
that our product supports but so do
a bunch of other
companies in this area
but the metrics
are just the starting point of a
fairness assessment
so for example
if you think about the disparate impact
ratio
uh in a
employment application and it's
measuring what's the proportion of
women who are hired rather relative to
the proportion of men who are hired
and and if that if there's a big gap in
that ratio let's say women are only
being approved or being hired at
80 percent of the rate at which men are
being approved
then the disparate impact ratio will say
that
there's an 80 percent
disparity between the two groups
that's a very useful metric to
signal the start of a fairness
assessment
but just reporting that is not enough
the next step in that workflow is to
do a root cause analysis
that identifies the reason for that
disparity
and
surface that
to human
assessors so for example in the
employment use case
one of the reasons for that could be
that
for this particular kind of job it
required a
college degree
in computer science
and the proportion of women who applied
for this job
that didn't have the college degree was
much higher than
that for men
so if you're able to surface that kind
of reason then a human in the loop can
then go on to make a judgment on whether
the statistical disparity is truly an
indicator of
unfair discrimination
or is it
for a justifiable reason
and it
and the kind of unfairness that's
emerging through this process needs to
be addressed not through
changes in the data or the machine
learning model but needs to be addressed
earlier in the pipeline through
interventions and education and so forth
so that's a powerful
set of capabilities here around
supporting a deeper root cause analysis
which can then inform adjustments to the
model
or when needed
and adjustments to the training data as
well
similarly similarly that kind of root
cause analysis is also supported
in
other parts
other kinds of ai quality attributes
related to why is the model performance
dropping
or
why is
why is
the model suddenly unstable is it
because the world has changed in a
specific way so that
we can surface that reason and then go
on to adjust the model of the
surrounding roots
so
the core explainability technology
support for deep root cause analysis
that supports
for fairness for stability
error analysis that helps with debugging
identifying model weaknesses and
debugging them those are some areas
where
there are distinctive and significant
advantages
over
uh
other other options in this space
and i think at a platform level one of
the big things is the universality
aspect that i touched on earlier
around supporting a rich class of models
and connections to data stores and
being able to work with
uh seamlessly with different deployment
got
platforms
um and and on that point from an
implementation standpoint um where does
true era fit in the modern data stack
that's a great question
you can think of us as
sitting
adjacent
to the training
and to the deployment
pieces of the stack
and then integrating with the with those
pieces
through certain kinds of connectors
so for example if i focus on the
diagnostics product which is
what model developers use during model
development
then
the
installation
and connectivity involves
building pipes to
get access to the models and to the data
sets
that are
uh used to train and test those models
so we support several different
experiences in this process
one is a web-based ui experience
where
after uh
after a model has been developed
there is a fairly easy way to using a
number of different interfaces to
push the models
onto our service along with pointers to
the data
and then the developers can use our ui
experience ui-based product to test and
debug and explain the models
and then there's a related experience
with notebooks where a lot of model
development in data science happens
through
notebooks and jupyter notebooks
and in this other experience they can
just stain their notebooks
and
have
interface with the
with our
service
through a set of api calls and they can
see all the visualizations and so forth
in the notebook itself
so that's a
tighter integration where
their life does not change much they can
just stay in their notebooks and work
with in their usual way
and leverage the capabilities that we
have for explaining and testing and
debugging models
got it
um super helpful
so
so a pum um we're almost out of time but
i just want to ask you
um
before you go
um you've seen a lot in the data
ecosystem in the last
10 15
years through your research and
your work on this ai quality problem
i'm curious like what's what surprised
you most through this journey
that's a great question um
i think one of the things that surprised
me the most is
the
recognition and willingness
in enterprises
to
do the right thing
so
in the sense that
there's a lot of a lot of discussion
these days around trustworthy machine
learning and responsible machine
learning
and some of it is coming because of
regulatory interventions and
and so forth
but what i find as we have engaged with
lots of customers in this space is that
there are a large number of folks data
scientists as well as
folks in leadership positions
who truly care about ensuring that the
machine learning models in the process
of delivering business value
are
mindful of the
societal impact that they have
so questions around explainability and
fairness
and and performance
and characteristics that might end up
denying opportunities or
offering opportunities in ways that can
hurt people long term
those are top of mind things for a
number of folks
i was pleasantly surprised to see that
many people are
receptive and also very
intentional
about
ensuring that
ai technology gets adopted in a way
that's responsible
and it's almost
instead of it being like a defensive
move in the sense that oh if we don't do
it it'll
it'll hurt us in some way through
regulatory intervention or
bad vr
there's there's increasing recognition
that adopting ai responsibly is good for
business
that
in fact
not only will it have a positive impact
on the world
it can actually boost the business value
of the core
yeah that's emerging from these core ai
capabilities
you might be able to reach a broader
section of
the uh
of the population
and include them financial inclusion
you might be able to
get to new segments that you had not
thought of before
and and that's that's that to me is was
the
was both a pleasant surprise and it
gives me a lot of room for optimism
that
we are starting to hit a phase shift
where there will be a bigger set of
adoption of ai at scale
in core areas of lots of different
verticals
and that
it'll be done in a way that
is responsible and it will be done in a
way that it'll generalize well and
perform well
in production
well um as you know i'm a supporter of
the company and your vision and
um it's great to hear your thoughts on
this broader ai quality
issue um i think sometimes
you know we can get lost in the weeds in
simple explainability or model
performance matters and so
it's great to hear
about your broader perspective
on on the ai quality space and
all the implications of that um so thank
you thanks for joining us on i'm excited
to see how the company tracks and i'm
looking forward to great updates from
you in the future
thank you pete it was a pleasure to have
this conversation with you and look
forward to continuing the conversation
this is a
very big area i would say this is one of
the
biggest
uh areas that will
support
large-scale and
positive adoption of
of ai and machine learning
and
so some of these sub areas that you
alluded to like explainability and model
performance and model governance
it's useful to think of them not as
separate areas but under one umbrella
around ai quality and that's the final
thought that i'll leave
you and our audience with
is to think about all of these sub areas
naturally plugged under
the ai quality
umbrella
and
and that will help us
that broader perspective i think will
help us
bring greater clarity and definition to
the field and to show its connection to
business and societal value
i agree
well thanks for thanks for joining us on
the palm
thank you
and uh
you too and thank you to all of our
listeners um who are out there
we are going to take a break for the
rest of the summer
but we'll be back with more amazing
guests and
new episodes of dc thursday in september
so everyone enjoy your summer and
stay safe and be well